stormy Daniels lawyer the esteemed
Michael avenatti was arrested on
suspicion of domestic violence the whole
story is pretty murky but it seems he's
accused of similar stuff he's partial to
smearing others with now I'm not gonna
lie I felt like there was some justice
exacted in the universe and I may be
small for feeling that way but nobody's
as small Petty and irresponsible with
the lives of others as this guy he tried
to ruin Brett Cavanaugh's life with
unbelievable allegations that had been
referred for Criminal Investigation that
wrongdoing requires serious poetic
justice and even if it turns out he's
innocent and he might very well be he's
tasting the kind of pain he's put on
others and it's good to see one leader
of a mob get hoisted on his own pizzas
feel good feels good one must resist
that feeling because someone else may
have gotten hurt the alleged victim so
we must be better than him better than
avenatti
okay that's a low bar we must be
magnificent compared to him so he
deserves due process and a presumption
of innocence even if he kept it from
Cavanaugh and he must get all that good
stuff our system has to offer even if he
would happily deny it to you or to me
and maybe if justice is served he might
learn something about his own behavior
his own sins and his own deceit buddies
Michael avenatti so don't hold your
breath
all right so one he claims he believes
that he was set up that he was framed
and he might have been framed who knows
but would it be more likely Democrats
than Republicans to frame him they got a
crowded field and he doesn't do any to
Democrats any favors you mean you really
think he's running for president well
maybe I just I you know of course I
thought Trump is right but that is
really ridiculous that's really
ridiculous but I must say there seems to
be a lot of shot and Freud around today
with regard to Michael I have an idea a
lot of people saying oh especially on
the right I think Town Hall had a
headline since I'm like sweet irony
right right so but I think this very we
should all be very careful we don't know
the facts of this case and I was
surprised that the first wife and the
second wife the second life I think
she wasn't there an initial report was
that she was there and that she was the
victim so that doesn't make sense to me
but I just think we're all locked into
this tribal political kind of framework
at the moment and avenatti has made
himself the titular head of the attack
on Donald Trump so if you're a trump
supporter why not take the light in his
troubles titular that is the best word
to describe him
Dana as much as I despise the guy you
have to presume he's innocent even if he
would screw you over in a heartbeat now
you have to because that's the principle
that we were arguing about all during
the Cavanaugh hearings I saw today that
the couple of New York Times reporters
are going to be writing a book it's
gonna be coming out next year and it's
I'm going to answer all the questions
still unanswered questions from the
Brett Kavanaugh confirmation hearings
and I thought really all the questions
yes like all the ones like the ones
including for example the people who've
been referred to Department of Justice
by the Grassley committee the Judiciary
Committee for making false statements to
investigators like those unanswered
questions yeah those would be
interesting there would and actually it
would be a great book if they went after
them if that's the book they're gonna
write that's focused on two weeks it
would be a great book Jesse you love to
read yeah but that's for another time it
is I know it's small and I am small but
I feel some justice to see how a vanetti
responds now that he's on the other side
of this that's kind of like I mean
that's a human thing and I realized that
I should I should tamp that down isn't
it funny how life can kind of just hold
the mirror up sometimes and show you
lessons learned possibly I mean it was
just a couple months ago that this exact
same thing was happening to Brett
Kavanaugh allegedly and he wasn't giving
him the benefit of the doubt so I think
it's nice than now everybody you know if
it happens to this person that it
happens this person the entire media can
take a step back and say innocent until
proven guilty
except Hillary cuz we know she's guilty
when you look at this guy it looks like
his life is flaming out
it looks like he's 15 minutes are up I
don't know if he did it he may have been
set up but let's just say something
happened that was bad he kind of rode
stormy Daniels lawsuit to fame and then
he parlayed into a presidential run and
then he's now
all being investigated for lying to the
Senate a judge this world he owes
millions to his former business partners
he's been accused of a felony domestic
assault beef and you're looking at this
guy and you're thinking okay how bad can
it get and then you say to yourself it's
gonna get a lot worse because one he's
never gonna get booked on any cable news
shows anymore everybody that loved him
CNN barely covered the story his
appearances in Vermont at some
Democratic event were canceled
this guy's a pariah and he's in the
middle of a really dirty divorce right
now and he can't afford the luxury
lifestyle that he's provided for himself
and for his ex-wife and I think what's
gonna happen is he was gonna take the
money that he raised for the
presidential campaign and I think he was
gonna pay down debts with that because
he owes his business partners he was a
state of California and he owes the IRS
millions of dollars that's over with now
that whole shell game that he was trying
to arrange is done
I think he's gonna probably declare
bankruptcy or he may spend time in
prison you're like the opposite of a
therapist you actually just basically
took apart every facet of his career
Jedidiah even Alyssa Milano who was you
know front and center almost in the
Cavanaugh hearings are in the back to
their shoulder just has disavowed him
yes she's consistent at least
presumption of innocence doesn't matter
to her no matter what no matter who it
is I think it's interesting at you know
you asked before how he might respond
and I saw that he tweeted out one of the
things he said when he tweeted was why
is TMZ's news standard the new standard
that's really interesting cuz that's
what some of many of us have been saying
for a really long time now all of a
sudden he's gonna become the guy that
questions these news outlets and says
wait a second you know this is an
accident accusation against me this is
an allegation of me there's no proof
he's making the exact same arguments
that everyone that was watching
Cavanaugh unfold and saying hold on a
second let's just investigate this and
figure out what happened but let's not
criminalize this guy in second one now
he's making those arguments this should
be like a moment for him a turning point
moment for him where he sits back if
he's you know a decent human being and I
don't
know him personally but if he is where
he sits back and he can say wow this is
why this matters because at any point
you could be in this situation I don't
know if he's guilty I don't know if he's
innocent I don't know what happened but
any one of us could be an in a situation
where the public doesn't know the story
but you deserve the right to be innocent
until proven guilty because no one else
knows the story except you and you have
to go through process no one gave cabin
on the right to process and now he's
seeing that a lot of people don't want
to give him that same right and many of
us are sitting here I don't agree with
him on anything but I am here to defend
his right to process the same way I was
defending cabin I was right to process
wellokay system she would be great for
me ask you a question Jedi you really
think and Jesse said this too it's
analogous
I think you were being unfair to
Cavanaugh I mean Cavanaugh was really
but the hard charge against him came
from Professor Ford who said something
happened when he was a teenager and then
they had to get her to testify and
they're trying to find if they could
confirm in the case of what we're seeing
with avenatti you've got the women right
there that investigation go I don't
think it's analogous and I certainly
don't think it's analogous to stormy
Daniels saying something happened with
Donald Trump and then discovering that
there was appeal but now everything is
the same it's all about due process come
on he still has a right to go have this
be investigated make his chase her that
was what the Democrats were saying about
category situations Cavanaugh was 30
years ago with no this is know nothing
that's what I say this will arrest
that's what I guess why it's not an
elegant it's even less analogous and the
burden of proof is more on have a
naughty but what is galih guess is that
the public should be willing to say
innocent until proven guilty
hold that were it's still America
regardless of what the situation it's
not the same exact situation you're
right there is an arrest here and you're
right it is arguably a much worse
situation for you but you still have
people still have a right to defend
themselves and we shouldn't be
criminalizing people on second you know
as I get more famous and powerful I've
noticed something I'm probably going to
get set up at some point you have some
great advice for people and I read
that's on Twitter today what if you're
ever traveling alone for like a period
of time and like really no one really
knows where you are it's good to make
purchases with a credit card or a debit
card that way there's an electronic
footprint that verifies your whereabouts
at a certain point of time so you have
an alibi so no one can say you did this
to me at this time you can say no no I
have lying tic-tac what happened what
happened when you gave me your Starbucks
card and I used it if everybody would do
that every criminal would do that yeah
it helps walk around using your ATM card
yeah that's very funny I'm glad you
thought about this yeah yes because it's
getting more famous by the